لا ابدا هذا قرار نهائي اقتضاه وضعي وسني
والمرحله التي دخلناها الان لم تعد مرحلتي
ولا مرحله امثالي لذلك خيرت ان اكون
مواطنا عاديا اعيش مع ابناء وطني لكن لا
اتحمل قيادتهم لان غير مؤهل لذلك احسن مني
هل تختلف اليوم يعني طريقه نظرتك
لتونس تغيرات والمشهد فيها يعني لما كنت
فاعل في الحراك السياسي والان بعد اعتزاله
وتحول الى مواطن كما تكون مواطن عادي
لا يعني المسار كانهم متكامل لانه ما نراه
اليوم من احداث
ويعبر عن
رغبتي هذا الشعب في ان يتموقع في ان يجد
لنفسه طريقا فان يخط لي نفسه مسارا في ان
يحقق لنفسه اهداف
وهذا المسار هو مسار ليس سهلا لانه ما صار
تغيير
تختلف عليه الاراء والافكار ولكن يبقى
طبيعيا ان يوجد بين افراد الوطن الواحد من
الخلاف ما لا يتجاوز حدود الارتباط بالوطن
ذاته وان يختلف داخل الوطن وان لا ينقلب
على الوطن وان لا ينسوا حقوق الوطن عليهم
ما معنى ذلك يعني
كيف تفسر بشكل مبسط
[موسيقى]
خلافنا ينبغي
مع ذلك ان خلافنا لا ينبغي ان يتجاوز
المسلمات الاساسيه من ارتباط بتاريخ
وارتباط بحضاره وارتباط بواقع وارتباط
بمصالح وان هذا الارتباط ينبغي ان يكون
منشاؤه وهدفه الوطن ذاته لا خدمه اغراض
خارجيه ربما او اغراض بعيده عن ما يعيشه
المواطن في احساسه وشعوره وتفكيره
يعني هل تعتقد انه اليوم الخلافات خرجت عن
المسلامات الاساسيه اللي وضعتها اللي هي
تاريخ الحضاره همم الوطن هل هناك يعني من
يخدم لاغراض خارجيه لاهداف خارجيه
على كل حال انا العلم الذي بذلك لكن الذي
اقوله وان علينا ان لا نتجاوز الى التكفير
او التخوين هذا اني امراني فيهما حكم على
انتماء الفرد
وفيهما اعتداء على مسلمات الوطن لا نكفر
بعضنا ولا نخون بعضنا وبعد ذلك كل
الخلافات يمكن ان تحل